hi schön dass ihr eingeschaltet habt zu
ZDF heute live ja genau an dieser Stelle
haben wir gestern über den Rücktritt der
Verteidigungsministerin Christine
Lambrecht gesprochen heute scheint schon
etwas mehr Klarheit zu herrschen
niedersachsens Innenminister Boris
Pistorius soll neuer
Verteidigungsminister werden wer das ist
wie das politische Berlin reagiert und
welche Herausforderungen jetzt in diesem
neuen Amt auf Boris Pistorius warten
darüber möchten wir heute sprechen zum
einen mit unserer
hauptstadtkorrespondentin Diana
Zimmermann und aber auch der
verteidigungspolitischen Sprecherin der
FDP Marie Agnes strak Zimmermann und wie
immer möchte ich nicht nur mit denen
sprechen sondern auch mit euch wir
wollen diskutieren uns austauschen wenn
ihr also Fragen zum Thema habt
Kommentare oder Anregung dann schreibt
uns die gerne hier einfach direkt in den
Youtube Chat oder per Mail an ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de jetzt sage ich aber
erstmal hallo Diana Zimmermann schön
dass du bei uns bist hallo guten Morgen
Diana wie überrascht warst du denn heute
von dieser Meldung des Buches Pistorius
neuer Verteidigungsminister werden soll
schon ein bisschen überrascht weil Boris
Pistorius jetzt nicht zu den Namen
gehörte die hier schon seit Tagen Wochen
manche sogar schon seit Monaten
gehandelt werden und das liegt unter
anderem daran dass er diverse Kriterien
die natürlich sind und manche die auch
die SPD und die Regierung sich selbst
gesetzt haben eigentlich nicht erfüllt
er hat abgesehen davon dass er in den
80er Jahren bei der Bundeswehr gedient
hat keine keine verteidigungspolitische
Erfahrung er ist ein ausgewiesener
Innenpolitiker und er ist natürlich
keine Frau darauf aber hatten die SPD
Frauen zuletzt noch mal sehr gedrungen
dass Olaf Scholz ihnen versprochen hatte
dass das Kabinett paritätisch besetzt
wird das hat er auch getan und sie
dränge darauf dass es das auch bleibt
das ist ein ganz offensichtlich wenn
Frau Lamprecht geht und her Pistorius
kommt nicht mehr der Fall und wie wir
hören soll es auch keine weitere
Umbildung des Kabinetts geben das sind
also zwei Kriterien die er nicht erfüllt
dazu hat sich die CDU bereits zu Wort
gemeldet und gesagt es sei enttäuschend
dass es wiederum nicht um Sachkompetenz
gehe und daraus kann man auch ablesen
dass dem Kanzler eben andere Kriterien
wichtiger sind ganz klar Loyalität
offensichtlich und zweitens
Durchsetzungskraft historius hat
natürlich Führungserfahrung außerdem ist
er ein sehr beliebter und erfahrener
Minister und die Bundesregierung hat
eine Pressemitteilung rausgegeben in der
sicherlich nicht ganz zufällig auch
davon gesprochen wird dass er ein großes
Herz habe daran so könnte man daraus
ablesen Schienen ist doch der
Vorgängerin etwas gemangelt zu haben
ja Diana wir werden darüber gleich noch
weiter sprechen wenn ihr Fragen an Diana
habt schickt sie gerne in den Chat oder
per Mail an uns jetzt möchte ich aber
einmal rüberschalten zuvor sitzen das
Verteidigungsausschusses Marie Agnes
Strack Zimmermann die heute ebenfalls
bei uns ist hallo Frau Strack zimmermann
ich grüße Sie ganz herzlich ich stelle
die gleiche Frage einfach noch mal an
sie wie überrascht waren sie denn heute
von dieser Meldung
ja ich war auch überrascht aber es
wurden ja viele Namen genannt aber ich
muss dazu sagen Olaf Scholz ist immer
für Überraschungen gut und auch mal so
ins Länder Tableau zu kommen zu schauen
da war der Name viel nicht bekannt aber
ich erlebe Prätorius in der
parlamentarischen Gesellschaft der NATO
da war er immer dabei das ist jetzt ein
Zirkel der nicht so bekannt ist in der
Öffentlichkeit insofern ja überrascht
aber jetzt nicht irgendwie entsetzt oder
so
mit ihnen möchte ich vor allem mal über
die inhaltlichen Herausforderungen
sprechen die dieses Amt mit sich bringt
wir wissen ja alle das sind einige und
was für Herausforderungen da im
Verteidigungsministerium auf Herrn
pistorisch warten das hat sich Thomas
Gonsior mal für uns angeguckt
Christine Lambrecht ist gegangen es
bleiben viele Probleme bei der
Bundeswehr grundsätzliche Probleme die
es schon lange gibt zum Beispiel
Materialprobleme viel Militärgerät ist
mangelhaft letztes Beispiel der
Schützenpanzer Puma er zeigte bei
Übungen Pannen und Hubschrauber der
Marine Ende des Jahres waren nur 30%
einsatzbereit und Militärgerät fehlt die
Bundeswehr kann derzeit keine
Artillerieverbände für Nato-Partner
Litauen stellen es gibt kein Gerät vor
allem weil das her Artillerie an die
Ukraine abgab überhaupt fehlt an
Ausrüstung Funkgerät und IT-Systeme sind
zu alt neues Material muss er doch es
gibt Beschaffungsprobleme der Kauf des
kampfliegers F35 aus den USA etwa ist
teuer und dauert lange
das was bisher entschieden worden ist
sind im Prinzip kauflösungen oder im
Wesentlichen kauflösung die über die
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
abgewickelt und gelöst werden das kann
kein Dauerzustand sein sondern es muss
auch darauf Auslaufen dass die deutsche
Rüstungsindustrie die europäische
Rüstungsindustrie entsprechende Aufträge
bekommt damit Sie alle leistungsfähig
bleibt und wie wir verliert nicht ganz
komplett abhängig werden von der
amerikanischen Seite überhaupt bestehen
Finanzprobleme zwar stellt der Bund der
Truppe ein Sondervermögen von 100
Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung aber die
stolze Summe reicht nicht so dass
Institut der deutschen Wirtschaft schon
2026 fehlen demnach knapp 10 Milliarden
Euro auch wegen Verpflichtungen
gegenüber der NATO Defizite Mängel
verursacht wohl auch durch
Führungsprobleme
Organisationsprobleme
2011 ist entschieden worden dass das für
das Großgerät oder für das Gerät in der
Nutzungsphase für
Beschaffung in insgesamt von von
Material von Informationstechnik und für
die Nutzung dass der entscheidende Punkt
dieses Amt den Koblenz und der
sprechende Abteilungsleiter im BMVg
verantwortlich sind diese Verantwortung
war früher beispielsweise bei den
Inspektoren und diese haben sich da
intensiv darum gekümmert das wäre
vielleicht gut wenn diese Verantwortung
an die spekteure auf der zurückgegeben
wurde bedeutet Verantwortung wieder
näher an die Truppe die Bundeswehr und
so viele Probleme in Zeiten von Krieg
und Krisen jede Menge zu tun jetzt für
die Nachfolge im
Verteidigungsministerium
[Musik]
ja eines der ersten Dinge die
angesprochen worden sind
Führungsprobleme die es da aktuell gibt
Fragen ist marie-angel Strack Zimmermann
trauen sie denn Herrn Pistorius diese
Führungsstärke zu
ja ich traue ihm das zu er muss
natürlich unter Beweis stellen er ist
Innenminister und als Innenminister
hatte Erfahrungen mit
Sicherheitsbehörden das heißt er weiß
auch so wie bei den Soldaten das
Polizistin Polizisten ihren Kopf
hinhalten und das ist schon mal eine
Erfahrung die ihr bei der Bundeswehr
mitbringt in einem langen Ende geht es
um Leben und Tod er ist Volljurist das
heißt sie sich mit Strukturen Strukturen
zu verändern ich glaube er ist auch er
hat auch eine kaufmännische Ausbildung
das hilft auch wenn es um das Geld der
Bundeswehr geht also alles in allem
traurig ihm das zu aber wir werden
natürlich nicht nur gerne mit ihm
zusammenarbeiten wir werden natürlich in
daran messen ob er durchsetzen stark ist
auch am Kabinettstisch sie haben gerade
gesagt er ist loyal ja
selbstverständlich wird er das sein dass
er der Kanzlerin nicht geholt das heißt
aber dass er die Interessen der Soldaten
und Soldaten die muss er wirklich am
Kabinettstisch auf den Tisch legen und
auch dafür streiten und auch so weit
gehen dass er auch was das Ukraine Thema
betrifft das hat er bei der NATO PV ja
mitbekommen die reden auch der
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer und der
Partner in der NATO dass er das auch
vehement vertritt und dann freuen wir
uns auf eine gute Zusammenarbeit
die sprechen ja gerade schon was an was
auch die Menschen in unserer Community
interessiert ich lese nämlich gerade
eine Frage von Christoph es auf Youtube
wie hat sich Herr Pistorius früher zum
ukrainekrieg und Waffenlieferungen
geäußert die sagen gerade sie haben ihn
da schon recht meinungsstark erlebt oder
ja also es ist nicht so bei so einer PV
ist jetzt nicht so dass da jeder in den
Ring steigt und 10 Minuten spricht die
Tatsache aber dass er Teil dieser
Parlamentarischen Versammlung der NATO
ist spricht natürlich dafür dass er ein
Interesse dafür hat und dass er hört was
die anderen Partner zu uns sagen
Erweiterung der NATO Schweden Finnland
da natürlich die Gespräche mit den
ukrainischen Freunden also den auch die
nicht in der Natur sind aber sozusagen
mit am Tisch sitzen das hat er alles
mitbekommen und er ist mir nicht
aufgefallen dass er dagegen ist
vielleicht darf ich das mal so rum sagen
okay wir haben ja also zum einen
vielleicht eine administrative Stärke
Führungserfahrung jetzt ist aber ja in
den letzten Wochen Monaten immer wieder
besprochen worden dass in diesem Amt
auch wirklich ein gewisser Draht zu
Truppe wichtig ist also eine persönliche
Verbindung zur Bundeswehr sehen Sie die
denn bei Herrn Pistorius
das kann ich natürlich noch nicht
beurteilen und da will ich jetzt auch
nicht vor schnell antworten aber ich
kann Ihnen sagen es gibt einige
Bedingungen die zu erfüllen sind also
Durchsetzungskraft im Bundesministerium
der Verteidigung bei der natürlich auch
bei allem Respekt auch behaarungskräfte
sind die dürfte er prätoris als
ehemaliger Oberbürgermeister aus der
Verwaltung sehr gut kennen da darf er
dieses Amt was er jetzt antritt nicht
als Karriere Sprungbrett nutzen und er
muss eben das große Herz von dem gerade
gesprochen wurde muss er für die Truppe
haben er muss die Brille der Soldaten
und Soldaten aufziehen und aus ihrer
Sicht argumentieren und zwar nicht nur
der generelle sondern auch der einfachen
Soldatin und Soldaten das ist die
Voraussetzung und da werden wir ihn auch
daran messen
hier kommt gerade noch eine Stimme aus
der Community an sie Frau Schrack
Zimmermann da sagt Vincenzo 030 also
einziges Kriterium war dass er mal
gedient hat das scheint diesem User ein
bisschen zu wenig so zu sein was können
Sie dazu sagen
ja das ist auch kein Kriterium ich weiß
natürlich wie jetzt keinen zu nahe
treten aber es gibt natürlich auch
Herren hier im Bundestag die sagen
Mensch endlich kommt er wieder ein Mann
endlich hat einer gedient ich glaube es
wäre dann übrigens der erste und einzige
im Bundeskabinett derer die gedient hat
nein das ist kein Kriterium dann wäre ja
jede Frau in der Sicherheitspolitik fehl
am Platz weil sie nicht gedient hat
nehmen Sie mich jetzt bin ich keine
Ministerin ich habe natürlich nicht
gedient weil ich ein Jahrgang bin
übrigens auch die wie die Vorgängerin
von Frau Lambrecht Frau
Kramp-Karrenbauer Frau von der Leyen wir
hätten selbst wenn wir gewollt hätten
nicht dienen können weil das schlichtweg
nicht möglich war also das ist natürlich
ein schmales Kriterium aber den Zugang
zu haben aus Niedersachsen kommt wo die
Bundeswehr sehr stark ist das trauen wir
ihm schon zu eine Schonfrist hat er
allerdings nicht also 100 Tage ist nicht
das muss sofort geklärt werden Rammstein
Format Lieferung von Leopard Panzer in
die Ukraine da muss er jetzt sofort an
ja das ist echt ein Schnellstart in den
Job ist gibt ja wie sie sagen diese
Woche schon wichtige Termine die so
neuer Minister antreten muss lassen Sie
uns noch mal von der Personalie auf die
inhaltlichen Herausforderungen schauen
wir haben es gerade in dem Stück gehört
es gibt irgendwie Materialprobleme es
gibt Beschaffungsprobleme und da denkt
natürlich erstmal jeder an diese 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen die er im
letzten Jahr eigentlich so mit der
Zeitenwende die Kanzler Scholz
angekündigt hat so einen hergegangen
sind wie läuft's denn da bisher ihrer
Meinung nach mit den 100 Milliarden
also 100 Milliarden ist eine Menge Geld
die gibt man nicht mal so eben aus wie
wenn man im Supermarkt mit dem Körbchen
rumgeht da haben wir einiges bereits auf
den Weg gebracht die Nachfolge des
Tornados schwerer Transporthubschrauber
bewaffnete Drohnen Ausstattung des
Heeres digital die dann grundsätzlich
die Ausstattung der Soldatin und
Soldaten das haben wir bereits auf den
Weg gebracht da kann er also das eins zu
eins übernehmen aber sie sagten es
gerade es geht natürlich noch um viel
mehr wir brauchen auf lange Sicht eine
konsequent erhöhten Etat im Wehrbereich
das heißt er wird auch da am
Kabinettstisch zu ringen müssen wir
müssen die zwei Prozent Ziel der NATO
erreichen das weiß er als Mitglied der
NATO TV das heißt all diese Dinge
dürften ihm klar sein die Frage ist wie
setzt er es um und das große Thema ist
dass der Beschaffung wir haben in
Deutschland
grundgesetzlich verankert dass das
militärische im Ministerium und das
zivile getrennt ist und das ist ein ganz
ganz großes Problem weil viele
Beschaffung laufen unter zivilen
Gesichtspunkten ich bringe ihn mal ein
Beispiel wenn ein Panzer Seitenspiegel
braucht weil man sagt wenn er die Straße
überquert das kommt natürlich vor ist er
Teil der Straßenverkehrsordnung dann
würden sie und ich sagen Leute das kann
jetzt nicht euer Ernst sein ist aber so
wenn der Puma Panzer eine austrittslücke
haben muss damit auch Schwangere
durchkommen dann sage ich Ihnen eine
Schwangere Soldatin wird überhaupt nicht
mehr im Puma transportiert werden das
heißt das sind Dinge die so zivilen
Charakter haben auf was man achten muss
wenn wir Zivil etwas anschaffen das muss
aufhören Militär ist das völlig anderes
da gelten andere Regeln und das ist auch
mein dringender Appell an den neuen
Bundesverteidigungsminister dass wir
rangehen diesen Paragrafen im
Grundgesetz zu ändern er ist Jurist er
weiß wovon ich spreche das müssen wir
nach ja über 60 Jahren Bundeswehr müssen
wir endlich ändern
das scheint also eine Herausforderung zu
sein bei der Beschaffung der
Militärexperte Thomas Wiegold hat
gestern im heute journal noch mal das
hier zum Sondervermögen gesagt
für dieses Sondervermögen ist bisher
bewilligt worden der Kauf der F35
Kampfflugzeuge aus den USA das werden an
die 10 Milliarden und das ist ein
wichtiger Punkt moderne digitale
Funkgeräte die sind aber erstmal
bestellt bis die ankommen wird auch noch
ein bisschen dauern alles andere ist
noch nicht mal bestellt worden und das
ist etwas was viele in der Bundeswehr
aufregt Stichwort z.B Munition da ist
klar für zehn manche sagen 20 Milliarden
Euro müssen die Munitionsvorräte
aufgefüllt werden aber auch da gibt es
noch keine Bestellung es hängt sehr viel
mit diesen ganzen Prozessen zusammen die
nötig sind damit Geld auch in Bewegung
gesetzt werden kann damit was eingekauft
werden kann also das Sondervermögen hat
ja der Kanzler Ende Februar angekündigt
im Sommer wurde es bewilligt und erst im
November hat der Haushaltsausschuss
angefangen bestimmte Gelder daraus
freizugeben für konkrete Projekte diese
ganzen Abläufe zeigen dass ich in den
Prozessen nicht viel geändert hat auch
wenn Krieg in Europa herrscht
ja also wir hören hier 100 Milliarden
das hat sicher erstmal viele beeindruckt
weil es eine wahnsinnig große Zahl ist
jetzt ist es aber so dass es anscheinend
Probleme gibt oder ist einfach schwierig
ist diese 100 Milliarden schnell auf die
Straße zu bringen wieso wurden die erste
wieso wurden die erste Mittel darauf
erst im November bewilligt
ja die die Einlassung gerade ist ja
völlig richtig das dauert alles viel zu
lange man muss natürlich eines sehen
dass natürlich auch Parlamentarier schon
wissen wollen wofür sie Geld ausgeben
ich möchte nicht in einem Jahr hier
stehen und sie werfen uns vor ihr habt
die Kohle darf ich das mal so salopp
sagen aus dem Fenster rausgeschmissen
und nicht mal nachgefasst worum es geht
also das ist ein längerer Prozess des
Jahr aber es stimmt die Prozesse müssen
verkürzt werden aber es müssen auch
Befehle erteilt werden das heißt
natürlich dass ein
Bundesverteidigungsminister auch sagen
muss wir wollen wir brauchen Munition
und muss diesen Prozess in Gang setzen
was eben nicht passiert ist Kanzler
Zeiten Wände dann still ruhte sie dann
ging das Stück für Stück und dann fehlte
eben eine Einlassung am Kabinettstisch
das was ich ihnen gerade gesagt habe
dass man sagt so wir müssen jetzt auch
nachbestellen übrigens auch in der
Diskussion möglicherweise den Leopard 2
in die Ukraine zu verlegen dann muss
auch klar sein dass es sofort bei der
Industrie neue Leopard 2 bestellt werden
diese wiederum in die Truppe erreichen
das heißt da muss befehlt werden
befehligt werden dann muss es umgesetzt
werden und der erwarte ich mir schon
dass der neue Minister ein ganz breiten
Rücken macht und das durchzieht
wir haben hier noch eine Frage aus der
Community an sie und zwar geht es um
Waffenlieferungen ob es noch eine Chance
gibt dass Pistorius Nein zu
Waffenlieferungen sagt irgendwie
beschleicht mich das Gefühl dem wird so
sein
also ich bin der optimistischer das weiß
man natürlich nicht aber ich kann Ihnen
nur sagen Herr pretoris ist ja nicht
allein in diesem Orbit er hat Partner
und die Freien Demokraten er braucht
eine Mehrheit ähm da sitzen noch Bündnis
90 die Grünen wir als Freie Demokraten
haben dann eine ganz klare Meinung die
ändert sich nicht und wenn er
erfolgreich in der Bundeswehr wirken
will wenn er wirklich als der Minister
in die Geschichte eingehen will der
endlich mal diesen Knoten durchschlagen
hat braucht er uns und deswegen kann ich
Ihnen nur heute oder ihm nur sagen wer
arbeiten gut zusammen aber wir erwarten
sofort dass die Ukraine weiter
unterstützt wird der Krieg tot während
wir sprechen sterben Menschen und ich
glaube dass er Prätorius sich diese
Situation durchaus bewusst ist
ja danke Frau stark Zimmermann für ihre
Einordnungen und für ihre Antworten ich
habe hier noch ein paar Kommentare aus
der Community die sie betreffen die Sie
vielleicht auch interessieren
anscheinend hätten sich mehrere User in
unserer Community sie als Nachfolgerin
gewünscht so schreibt er hier Lee ins
strandzimmer man hätte ich gut gefunden
statt Zimmermann werden Alternative
gewesen schade dass Frau strafzimmer
nicht Ministerin geworden ist danke
schön dass Sie bei uns waren wir
schalten jetzt noch mal rüber zu meiner
Kollegin Diana Zimmermann heute äh das
große Zimmermann fest hier und mit ihr
möchte ich noch mal weiter über die
Personalie sprechen hallo Diana hallo
genau wir haben eben die Meldung
bekommen dass es ein
Pressestatement gibt vom Sprecher der
Bundesregierung Steffen Hebestreit ich
zeige euch das mal hier auf dem PC wir
können das ja mal kurz durchgehen
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz wird Boris
Pistorius 62 Jahre als neuen
Verteidigungsminister ins Bundeskabinett
Berufen am Donnerstag wird der
langjährige niedersächsische
Innenminister seine Ernennungsurkunde
vom Bundespräsidenten erhalten und im
Deutschen Bundestag sein amtseit leisten
ich freue mich sehr mit Boris Pistorius
einen herausragenden Politiker unseres
Landes für das Amtes
Verteidigungsministers gewonnen zu haben
Pistorius ist ein äußerst erfahrener
Politiker der verwaltungserprobt ist
sich seit Jahren mit Sicherheitspolitik
beschäftigt und mit seiner Kompetenz
seiner Durchsetzungsfähigkeit und seinem
großen Herz genau die richtige Person
ist um die Bundeswehr durch diese
zeitenwände zu führen sagt Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz am Dienstag in Berlin
Diana
wie schätzt du dieses Statement ein und
mich interessiert und ich glaube auch
viel in der Community was sagst du zu
diesem zu dieser Sache mit dem großen
Herz ist das wirklich eine Qualität die
es in diesem Amt braucht
ja also das ist ja ein bisschen auch das
was Frau stark Zimmermann gerade gesagt
hat dass man eben die Truppe hinter sich
bringen muss und dafür braucht man
wahrscheinlich irgendeine Form von
großem Herzen dann brauchst zumindest
eine direkte Ansprache und irgendwie
eine Verbindung dann hat es Frau
Lambrecht eben gemangelt und man sieht
ja an dieser Aufzählung die Olaf Scholz
vornimmt dass er erfahren hervorstreicht
verwaltungserfahren bedeutet also
Führungsrolle Entschuldigung
Führungsrolle in einem großen Apparat
und das war teilungsministerium ist eben
sehr groß er die er spricht von
Sicherheitspolitik das ist ähm die
elegante umschiffung von nicht
vorhandener
verteidigungsverteidigungspolitische
Erfahrung aber doch mit Hoffnung auf
sich noch zu erwerbende Kompetenz und
ähm wir kommen natürlich wieder auf den
Punkt dass es keine Frau ist und
insofern ist Boris pistorie ist
natürlich auch wirklich eine
überraschende Entscheidung denn er wurde
gehandelt als möglicher Nachfolger
sollte Nancy fazer tatsächlich ihre
Kandidatur erklären um politische
Ministerpräsidentin werden zu wollen und
dort in den Wahlkampf hin abzuziehen für
diesen Posten war Pistorius im Gespräch
als Bundesinnenminister und dafür fällt
er jetzt natürlich aus
du hast es gerade schon angesprochen
dadurch das Buch pistorisch ein Mann ist
in diesem Amt ist ja das Kabinett nicht
mehr paritätisch besetzt so wie es die
Ampelkoalition oder der Kanzler
eigentlich zu Amtsantritt festgelegt
hatte wie wirkt das auf dich ist das
jetzt unsouverän oder ist das genau der
richtige Schritt also es ist sehr laut
geworden in den letzten Tagen das ist
natürlich vor allen Dingen um die
Kompetenz gehen muss nachdem die letzte
Besetzung fehlgeschlagen ist das kann
man glaube ich nicht anders nennen ist
es natürlich wirklich jetzt wichtig da
jemanden sitzen zu haben der kompetent
ist und Kompetenz richtet sich an zwei
Fragen aus Sachkompetenz also
verteidigungspolitische Erfahrung der
hat ja eben nicht und die
Führungserfahrung und ganz
offensichtlich ist Urlaub Stolz der
Ansicht die Führungserfahrung ist jetzt
wahnsinnig wichtig dann allerdings lässt
sich natürlich die Frage stellen warum
er dafür nicht auch eine andere Frau hat
da werden die SPD Frauen sicherlich noch
mal laut werden und auch die Grünen sind
damit sicherlich nicht zufrieden dass
das jetzt so gelaufen ist
ich schaue hier noch mal in die Fragen
aus der Community und wir haben ja eben
schon so ein bisschen über Geld
gesprochen Geld für die Bundeswehr es
ist immer diese Summe von 100 Milliarden
im Umlauf die wahnsinnig groß ist aber
wie wir sehen es ist auch gar nicht so
einfach diese Mittel wirklich dann
abzurufen und hier fragt der YouTube
User Daniel g zwischen 2011 und 2022
sind 650 Milliarden Euro in die
Bundeswehr geflossen dennoch schießt
nichts fährt nichts und selbst an
Kleidung fehlt ist und ich finde er
stellt sich eine Frage was ich sicher
die sich sicher viele Menschen da
draußen stellen was ist denn mit dem
Geld passiert man hört immer von großen
Summen wo versickern die was passiert da
kannst du uns das sagen das kann ich
wirklich nicht es gibt einen extrem
komplizierten Ablauf im
Verteidigungsministerium dass das
sogenannte Beschaffungswesen da geht es
darum wie Material eingekauft wird und
dann liegt wohl wirklich sehr sehr viel
im Algen das Problem ist auch dass viele
das viel des militärischen Geräts nicht
richtig funktioniert also diese
berühmten Puma Panzer die unglaublich
viel Geld kosten aber dann eben
ausfallen wenn Übungen sind dann gibt
das ist das Problem dass viele von
diesen Gerät gar nicht kriegstauglich
ist also das ist eben in Friedenszeiten
angeschafft und nicht dafür vorgesehen
tatsächlich im Krieg eingesetzt zu
werden den haben wir jetzt aber also es
gibt glaube ich viele Löcher durch die
da Geld geflossen ist es ist natürlich
auch alles wahnsinnig aufwendig
wahnsinnig teuer und mit einer riesigen
Logistik versehen die Bundeswehr und
Tatsache ist wir sind für das was da
momentan passiert nicht gut aufgestellt
und das muss Herr pistorisches sehr sehr
schnell angehen
ja also wir merken super viele große
Herausforderungen für dieses Amt und wir
haben auch gestern schon kurz darüber
gesprochen es ist ja jetzt nicht so dass
Frau Lambrecht quasi das alles zu
verantworten hat sondern dass man sich
da ja wirklich in diesem Ministerium was
eines der schwersten oder der größten
Aufgaben ist im Kabinett gerade mit
einer Zeiten Wende
auseinandersetzen muss die da einfach
gerade weltpolitisch passiert du hast es
eben schon angesprochen es geht nicht
mehr so sehr um die alten Aufgaben die
die Bundeswehr mal hatte sondern jetzt
geht es wieder mehr um wirklich
landesverträgen und bündnisverteidigung
oder das ist ja eine ganz neue Sache ja
und Scholz hat ja selbst gesagt er
möchte dass Deutschland in dieser
Verteidigung der Ukraine und in der
Hilfe für die Ukraine eine Führungsrolle
übernimmt und das ist eben bisher nicht
gelungen weil Frau Lambrecht mit so
vielen kleinen und mittleren Skandalen
beschäftigt war der Kanzler hat relativ
viel der Verteidigungspolitik übernommen
die Frage ist jetzt ob das so
weitergehen wird wahrscheinlich nicht so
wie man Boris Pistorius einschätzen muss
lässt er sich da wahrscheinlich nicht so
viel rein reden oder wegnehmen und das
ist eventuell auch eine Hoffnung des
Kanzlers dass er eben jetzt jemanden hat
der dieses Amt wahrscheinlich mit seinem
relativ großen Selbstbewusstsein
ausfüllen wird
wir haben hier noch eine Frage aus der
Community
und zwar fragt User Chris whats auf
Youtube welche Voraussetzungen und
Erfahrungen bringt Boris Pistorius mit
in das neue Amt hat er bereits
Ministerien umstrukturiert in seiner
politischen Arbeit kannst du uns dazu
sagen was er vielleicht in Niedersachsen
schon gemacht hat
ich bin keine niedersächsische
politische Journalistin das weiß ich
nicht ich weiß aber dass er sehr beliebt
ist in Niedersachsen dass er als sehr
durchsetzungsstark gilt als jemand der
Strukturen gut erkennen und angehen kann
dass weiß ich schon und insofern ist das
sicherlich eines der Kriterien die
Scholz angelegt hat nachdem so viele
andere Kriterien die man hätte anlegen
können ausfallen muss man davon ausgehen
dass der Kanzler darauf vertraut dass er
das hinkriegt
schauen wir mal
ja wir schauen mal Danke Diana dass du
unsere Fragen auf der Community und auch
meine Fragen beantwortet hast ich werfe
zum Schluss noch mal einen Blick ein
bisschen in die Stimmung im Chat hier
gibt es einen Kommentar der sagt
Lambrecht war doch nur der Prellbock für
Scholz der wollte niemanden der sich
auskennt weil das besser weil das bremst
oder hier auch ein pessimistischer
kommentar von Helga Neudeck wer es ist
steht gar nicht zu debat wer ist steht
gar nicht zu Debatte hauptsache er tut
das was alle Politiker sagen ändern wird
sich nichts nur ein neuer Name andere
Person das ist alles was ich ändert
nicht jeder neue Besen kehrt gut ja wir
haben es eben schon gehört in dieser
Woche stehen ja noch einige wichtige
Termine für den neuen
Verteidigungsminister an und wie er sich
da schlägt da bleiben wir auf jeden Fall
für euch dran hier bei ZDF heute live
danke für eure Fragen danke fürs
einschalten und bis zum nächsten Mal